I want to know the story of how dolly
became your godmother well we started
doing Hannah Montana and she was kind of
plain like my aunt and she doesn't
really let me call her a godmother she
likes fairy godmother much better what
is it about dolly and why is she so
deserving of this honor tonight
number one or kindness legend definition
of a legend I mean she's dolly
Miley says that she's just an
inspiration for everyone kind beautiful
talented amazing she meant to you as a
woman in this business as an
entrepreneur as a woman as an
inspiration and as someone who's had a
very long career have you looked up to
her I'm blowing my punchline of my
speech tonight but I'm saying
she teaches people not to judge a book
by it's cover or it's huge boobs and
it's big hair thanks for talking to me
where you like did you look at your
outfit tonight you know I'm gonna need
to wear the most sparkly thing I own cuz
this dolly everything I own is sparkly
do you have a favorite song you have a
favorite dolly moment that you've shared
with her tonight I'm doing I've done
Jolene you know 20 times with dolly and
tonight I'm doing islands in the stream
which Shawn Mendes so I'm excited about
that I heard a rumor that there's new
music coming with Shawn a possible
collaboration everyone will have to
watch on Sunday the Grammys okay I do
want to ask you about the blanket on
camera and you liked our wedding guests
Wow Wow it's cozy it's for when you're
watching drag race with Miley who are
these people this is oh it's me it's me
my wife that's great
we love the blanket my mom was wanting
to text you we loved it so much my dogs
steal it most of the time anything
comfortable
the dogs steal but it's ours yes are you
married light thank you I'm good I'm
doing good better than ever
[Music]
[Applause]